recently in the South of France the
eloquent miss Katherine Hepburn took
time out from filming the lion and
winter to hearken back to the day at
Warner Brothers when the greatest
entertainer of his time Al Jolson
startled the world with sudden delight
when he spoke from the screen for the
first time
in 1927 those immortal words broke the
voice barrier and judging by what we're
seeing these days I would say that Al
Jolson was right 1927 was the year that
brought us I quote from the
advertisement of the day pictures that
talk like living people also in 1927 the
newly formed Motion Picture Academy
decided that it should give awards for
outstanding achievement the question was
what kind of an award
Cedric Gibbons head of MGM's art
department came up with the answer now
familiar to all of us
Oscar a man holding a crusader sword and
standing on a reel of film that's a very
moving idea if you really think about it
because that is exactly what all the
contenders are doing here tonight you
are standing on your reels of film
originally it was voted upon by a Board
of Directors numbering 18 people now it
is voted upon by the entire Academy
membership we number 3009 among the
characterizations honored during that
first decade where a southern belle a
lady barber
and three young actresses playing
actresses
among the men a prime minister
a scientist a king and a Portuguese
fisherman
it was a hell of a long time ago but we
weren't bad
the most honored film of that first
decade one that won five Oscars was a
simple and unpretentious film done in a
new and improvised style the remarkable
Frank Capra's it happened one night
to continue our retrospection of the
Academy's 40 years of service to our
Arts and Sciences let us go to France
dick Dunlop took his camera there last
month and sought the artistry that
matched the splendor of the louis xvi
room at versailles
here is the awards and heart winning
miss Olivia de Havilland in 1940 the
Academy decided it would be fun to make
nervous wrecks of the nominees for the
first time the winners were kept in
total secrecy until the Oscars were
actually announced from then on if the
evening was warm we sat there frozen if
the weather was chilly we sat there
smothering until the breathless month
when the now-famous envelope made its
appearance then we tried to stay alive
until it was opened during the second
decade the Academy acclaimed as Best
Picture three films which reflected the
war years the memorable mrs. Miniver
Casablanca and the best years of our
lives and continued to honor players in
roles covering the dramatic rainbow a
song-and-dance man
two priests
a soldier and another soldier there were
also two very noble self-sacrificing
mothers
and a southern belle
and the film most honored in this second
decade the story of another seventh
there this film was awarded eight Oscars
gone with the wind to guide us through
the third decade of Oscars history here
is the lovely actress who won the Award
for her performance in country girl and
now she's got her own country
here's miss Grace Kelly speaking from
the Louis the 15th room in the little
Palace on the hill overlooking downtown
Minako
the third decade was a decade of firsts
for the first time film made abroad was
honored as the best picture of its year
the British made Hamlet for the first
time a musical made abroad was honoured
that lovely not to be forgotten an
American in Paris and Oscar made his
first appearance on television and
became a citizen of the world for when
Hollywood's domination of its own awards
was challenged by films from other
countries this member of the Academy is
very proud to say that it responded with
courtesy and appreciation Bert promptly
established a new award for the best
foreign language film but in addition in
these 10 years how many nominations
would you guess were voted two foreign
films and artists would you believe 119
some of the acting awards of this decade
went to a prince
and princess a vagabond and another
princess
a sheriff
a prisoner and a faithful wife two films
of this decade tied for the most honors
each winning eight Oscars one was based
on a novel that just couldn't be made
into a movie From Here to Eternity and
the other was that equally hard-hitting
equally realistic on the waterfront
completing our review of Oscars
biography here's a former Award winner
and current nominee the extraordinarily
talented Miss Anne Bancroft tonight the
Academy celebrates the end of its fourth
decade and though his spirit is as young
as ever
Oscar is entering middle age he's even
gained weight back in 1928 II weigh just
under 7 pounds and today he weighs 11
isn't that interesting
during this decade the Academy honored
actors and actresses in the roles of a
handyman and a housekeeper a lawyer
I teacher
and a shrew a professor
and a nursemaid and the most honored
film in the history of the Academy was
part of this decade the winner of 11
Awards then her as Ben Hur was the most
honored film the man most honored was
the winner of 30 personal Oscars it was
a truly remarkable talent Walt Disney
and he gave us the most dashing
dauntless hero in the annals of the
screen 40 years of the magic talking
Lantern 40 years of memories ah but in
the 40 years and with some folks you
ain't heard nothing yet